on va d'abord appelée c8 d'or ce qui
s'est passé beaucoup de choses cette
année on télé et le premier civil wigdor
ces leucémies d'or de la séquence t d
qui mériteraient à celui qui a trouvé
l'idée de finir en garde à vue alors
selon vous qui mérite ces huit d'or
l'hologramme de kenji l'ange the voice
le jésus des coupes oui dans district z
ou le déguisement de patron incognito
regard des catégories de la séquence
télé qui méritera son auteur de finir en
garde à vue les nommés sont the voice
avec le lot g de kenji c'est assez
spectaculaire on ne l'a jamais fait dans
les os moi j'avais jamais vu ça on l'a
répété c'est au top
en pleurs
pour mieux s'aimer
quatre ans de ses parents
vu comment fermer les yeux
sur la
entre 1,2 et pendant
ce port
amis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
district z et l'épreuve incroyable de
découpage de fruits avant tout
[Applaudissements]
oui à la voilà le ghana fait c'est un
plein axe franchement c'est pas mal
patron incognito avec ses déguisements
ripoux changement de look qui va
surprendre et amuser nos deux patrons
[Musique]
jennyfer
alors pour vous qui mérite le suit
mackenzie programme
quels districts z district l'épreuve de
fruits et l'énigme l'épreuve de fruits g
changement de look derrière petite
parenthèse vous avez remarqué le
changement de look de pernikoff vu qu'il
y avait un nouveau bouc
oh oui c'est ce qu'on appelle un made in
book non les cherry pour moi je pense
qu'on est tous d'accord
la séquence a pleuré toute l'année et
pas déshonoré at on précisé
c'est très prétentieux package il est
jamais prétentieuse non non locales
annoncées sans grand effet tellement
claqué vendu pixar qui avaient fait le
trou à greek parmi le bol pour sa
centrale pour cette merde voilà les
pauvres ils se sont faits en brune à
côté deux cent mille euros
cette merde oui cet abri non mais un
truc comme ça ouais avec deux cent mille
euros n'ont fait dix-huit prime voici la
deuxième catégorie
dans la catégorie de l'homme politique
le plus dark à du paf
les nommés sont jean-michel blanquer
requis danse
e
françois bayrou et son masque à france
inter en avril 2010 8 40% des français
faisait confiance à emmanuel macron dans
les sujets de sécurité comment vous
expliquer cela
il faut l'union parce que le pays va mal
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une volonté jean
castex et ses lunettes
mais
bien mesdames et messieurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le matin je crois qu'ici c'est bayrou
voulait vendre sa ses huit ans à la
troisième catégorie catégorie de la
personne qui aurait dû prendre de la
camomille mais qu'on adore les nommés
sont les spectateurs de roland garros à
monsieur le journaliste je suis ici sur
cette mane vous savez du village merci
un auditeur de julien courbet bonjour en
main je me présente romain ce n'est pas
une blague
je suis julien courbet nous sommes en
direct sur la rue ma mère et ma grand
mère ça fait quand même beaucoup
la dame qui on veut un autre président
ma grande taille et de chants narrant
les lots d'habitation macro police à
niort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
samoa à winneba darker ouais c'est pas
d'arrêter un peu mieux les idées 6
cellules et non mais elle est quand même
dit ce qu'il pense a dit ce qu'il pense
mais c'est très drôle moi pour moi c'est
vrai sultan on dirait qu'il dort plus on
embrasse d'ailleurs julien courbet
attention le ses mines d'or de la plus
grande chaîne de hmam mais qu'on adore
regarde dans la catégorie de la plus
grande chaîne de hmam et qu'on adore les
nommés sont ces 8es les problèmes de
sons dans tpm p donc là il ya des
problèmes de son sachez le
donc voilà
chaque minute qui passe est une minute
gagner ce soir les séries vous me le
dites bien entendu s'il ya toujours des
poèmes de son sillage
malheureusement et vous verrez ça
commence bientôt 1000 bahts rc8 pour
avoir diffusé une pub sur des steaks
après un sujet vegan sur quoi les
candeur humeur était calqué sur
l'élevage et me l'a fait et elle va même
architecture que je fais de change
merci sur le bec merci baptiste voilà je
voulais pas la télé et au delà
alors c'est qui la star du barbecue
c'est les rives de madrange c'était
votre programme avec les rythmes dams
6,8 pour avoir diffusé deux fois la
suite enquête sous haute tension à
quelques kilomètres de là une autre
patrouille assure une mission de
surveillance dans un quartier où la
contrebande a pignon sur rue
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres de là une autre
patrouille assure une mission de
surveillance dans un quartier où la
contrebande a pignon sur rue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci merci manche les noyades et ses
enquêtes express et leur encadrement
sont deux fois et je gère la dengue a
c'est que le deuxième a mieux marché que
premier la route et une énorme d'arcade
ils ont enlevé les deux fois le même
scénario ne parle pas de rendement mais
chez les autres catégories le c8 d'or de
la personne qui a lâché la rampe mais
qu'on adore regarde dans la catégorie de
qu'on adore les nommés sont jean marie
bigard et les décideurs les décideurs
cette vallée décideurs n'est autre que
je n'ai rien avant les cannes et deux
sur 100 millions mais c'est eux qui
décident donc je te parle des décideurs
quand un homme politique vient te dire
que le conseil scientifique
ils sont aux ordres du pognon jean-marie
vous avez une rage incroyable alain
finkielkraut complètement à l'ouest sur
ses news
je suis très content de recevoir à la
finkielkraut
monsieur finkielkraut je répondre tout
de suite la has a commencé oui ça a
commencé l'émission a commencé on est à
l'antenne depuis cinq minutes
jean pierre pernaut et savane sur les
boules les boules de noël des gliomes
torreilles il a les plus belles boules
du paf m'a-t-on dit il on va essayer de
détrôner le gagnant ouais c'est cet
avion on verra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour moi c'est pascal braud pour quel
coût
alors on étale en tête mais ce qu'il
faut c'est le silence en fait on a plus
l'habitude à la tv de styles en quart
c'est qu'il ya un moment suspendu
c'était incroyable c'était magnifique
les chéris pas passé au ces huit d'or du
fou rire qui ferait même rire nicolas
pernikoff nicolas pernikoff zone
rappelle qu'il est aux coyotes
cet été sa cote est de sophia antipolis
à côté de cannes voilà donc si vous
n'avez pas les reins solides avec l été
cette route prenez bien sûr un
itinéraire de se regarder dans la
catégorie du fou rire qui ferait même
rire nicolas pernikoff les nommés sont
l'équipe du 6 à 7
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire lohan
allait régulièrement à l'hôpital elle
est suivie à des amis qui sont là pour
elle c'est vrai que la démo projet en
courant elle sera discutée elle prépare
un cabaret c'est bien mais très bien
vraiment vraiment d'accord c'est pas
bien ce que vous faites séditieux je
tenais à vous dire je vous ferais je
vous mets un blâme et je mets un carton
jaune pour cette remarque c'est un signe
aux jeux vous je me vengerai nicolas
pernikoff je vous jure que je me
vengerai on va faire un point sur tout
élément derrière en plus on va faire le
point sur michel bancaire
pascal praud sur ses news voilà
quelqu'un qui s'est retroussé les
manches
l'esthéticienne et elle a changé de job
et elle travaille dans un abattoir mais
c'est la mobilité c'est bien moi je
trouve c'est formidable parce que voilà
quand on veut on peut
l'instrument pauvres bêtes allons-y
[Rires]
anne sophie lapix pendant son jt une
nouvelle tribune de militaires a été
publiée par le magazine valeurs
actuelles elle évoque elle aussi le
délitement de la france mais aussi le
risque d'une guerre civile
les signataires sont des militaires
d'activé et rapt et autre épée mais nous
n'avons pas les noms ici ils sont restés
anonymes
la ministre des armées et florence parly
a dénoncé une groupie l'oxydation
politique pardon l'ogre des ardennes est
mort le tueur en série
[Musique]
c'est jérôme béglé notre nom à un ami
voilà que geobra dure aux médias
pernikoff de surtout pas parler des
projets de loana bah ouais là dedans et
on retrouve les ouïgours auraient
contacté le fruit est allé un quart
d'heure on espère qu'il viendra nous
voir
anne-sophie l'aller c'est bien aussi
parce que c'est celle qui est drôle les
séries on va donner à casta genton et
les cherry on a le c builder de la
personnalité en manque de calcium
également regarder catégorie de la
personnalité en nombre de calcium les
nommer son candidat de l'amour est dans
le pré minuit vient de sonner et l'heure
est venue pour jc d'exhiber à yolanda sa
parade nuptiale à poil
[Musique]
joe biden qui monte dans son avion
plus
[Musique]
christophe beaugrand au grand concours
des animateurs mais ça glisse bien tu
étais pas fait mal aux j'en ai vu
d'autres
[Musique]
exhiber un violent mal à sa parade
nuptiale à poil
[Musique]
et enfin l'or c'est un peu plus sérieux
c'est plus dans la cu là c'est renoncer
plus sérieux c'est vraiment l'image de
la saison pau 1 vraiment pas dans tpm p1
images d'actes de la saison regardez les
trois nommées là ya pas de vannes on
regarde dans la catégorie de l'image de
la saison
les nommés sont la prise du capitole
[Applaudissements]
la gifle sur emmanuel macron la première
personne vaccinée non une passion une
grand-mère nord-irlandaise de 90 ans
margaret keenan a reçu une injection
dans un hôpital de coventry centre de
l'angleterre fait par une par une
infirmière avec le sourire avec le
masque aussi bien évidemment elle a
également déclaré que si elle l'a fait à
90 ans et bien tout le monde pouvait le
faire
[Musique]
ouais ouais alors l'image de l'année les
garder la gifle alors la gifle alors on
va appeler alors il ya vu le parce qu'il
est passé directement là on en a on a
les quatre mois ferme et mois de prison
dont 14 avec sursis à mes quatre ferme
et un mandat de dépôt requis
il m'aimait il a dix jours pour faire
appel est ce que vous trouvez que c'est
beaucoup et risquaient trois ans de
prison
c'est pas énorme je trouve y sentir bien
franchement et qu'ils en tirent bien ou
pas c'est qu'il trouve que c'est pas
assez
il les a mises en scène non moi je
trouve que c'est thomas payet quand même
une peine de prison sans sursis global
moi je trouve que c'est correct
enfin moi aussi je croyais que les ben
moi je trouve que le message il est pas
très bon parce que la plante personnes
qui seraient capables de faire quatre
modes présente en effet un président
message il aurait été viré comme la
vertu de fonctionner comme la première
fois quand on a saisi sarkozy par le col
nicolas sarkozy avait rien eu le mec il
avait par essence saison et ça c'est un
train dans ce message là le mec qui met
une gifle mk3 faire c'est honteux mais
qui prennent des quatre mois c'est un
message envoyé aux juifs le pal présent
il ya les urnes si vous voulez apprendre
avec le présent vous allez donc la jif
les présents que le mec aille en prison
moi qu'on dise que des scans de nicolas
bonnière avertissements faut bien dire
aux gens qui va passer quatre mois en
prison enfermé n'a pas apprécié le
message devrait n'y a pas de sursis il
va aller en prison pour de vrai quatre
mois c'est long quatre mois il va y
aller var et fait maison
réfléchissez bien on va pas lui mettre
21 mai savait à l'avancé que j avais du
sursis pour sarkozy avait du sursis moi
je suis content qu'ils aient dû ferme
parce que si vous n'êtes pas content
vous lisez les programmes vous avez dans
les yeux ou mal soucier vous réglez ça
pour vale servent à rien il ya du feu
n'a pas porté plainte exactement voilà
en tout cas pour vous c'est que c'est
quoi les moi moi moi supporter l'image
du vaccin exactement c'est ça voilà je
suis d'accord c'est la seule image
d'espoir pour acheter quoi
valérie manier